[Inaudible].
Hello everyone. Welcome to the Lang focus channel. And my name is Paul today's.
Topic is Jamaican Creole, also known as Patois.
Jamaica is an Island nation in the Caribbean with a population of only around 3
million people,
but it's made a cultural impact around the world because of its art forms such
as reggae and dance hall music, as well as dub poetry.
Many English speakers have had the experience of hearing someone from Jamaica,
speak and understanding a little bit of it, but not most of it.
I mean, not in good Tal why then people are really, really, we could not tell
[inaudible] tell us about why they started feeding the Pitney Gardner.
That's because Patois partly descended from English, but not entirely.
It's an English based Creole language that developed in the 17th and 18th
centuries through contact between African slaves and English speaking,
slave owners,
the Island of Jamaica was first colonized by the Spanish who brought the first
African slaves there end in slave to the native title people until they were
wiped out by violence and disease,
but it was after the Island was taken over by Britain in the year 1655 that the
African population rapidly grew as the British brought slaves from West Africa
to work on sugarcane plantations.
These Africans were intentionally separated from others who spoke the same
language as them.
So they wouldn't be able to communicate in secret and plan a rebellion with no
common language.
They did their best under harsh conditions to use the English dialects spoken by
their slave masters.
They didn't learn the language formally and they had to learn the language very
quickly, which resulted in the development of a pigeon language.
They adopted a basic vocabulary of English words and strung them together using
a simplified form of the grammar of their native languages.
Eventually when they had children,
those children learned the simple pigeon language as their native language,
but expanded its features and use making it a living language used for all parts
of life. That was when the pigeon language became a Creole language.
The term pathway comes from French and can be used generally to refer to any
kind of non-standard speech.
But it's also how Jamaicans refer to their Creole language.
Not all Jamaican Patois is the same.
There are various regional and local varieties around the Island.
One reason is that the slave owners spoke various different dialects of English.
Another reason is the mountainous terrain that isolation of the different
plantations and communities from each other.
When a pigeon language becomes a Creole,
it becomes more complex and new features arise to make the language sufficient
for everyday use. That means that in communities, isolated from each other,
the new features might've been different.
Also the official language of Jamaica is not Patois,
but English and Patois is spoken on a continuum with standard Jamaican English.
That means that in some situations,
some speakers will essentially be speaking standard English with a
characteristically Jamaican accent. While in other situations,
some speakers will mix English with varying degrees of Patois.
And at the very casual end of the spectrum,
speakers might use Jamaican Patois exclusively in technical terms,
pure Patois is the basil elect while standard English is the acro elect.
And in the middle lies,
the mezzo elect the acro like standard English is the prestige language and the
language of social mobility while Patois is sometimes considered to be incorrect
English or improper speech.
But Patois is a distinct language with its own phonology,
grammar and vocabulary distinctions.
There's also another form of Patois called Crow Monte or deep Patois,
which was used by the Maroons descendants of slaves who escaped from the Spanish
when the British invaded Jamaica and set up communities deepen the mountains.
This form of Patois is more heavily based in the Aecon language than other forms
of Patois. Deep Patois is now used as a ritual language in maroon communities,
but not as a daily spoken language.
Vocabulary.
We already have Patois vocabulary. It comes from English,
but with pronunciation that has diverged widely from English,
there's technically no standard way to write Patois only general tendencies.
But those differences from English are usually reflected in Patois spelling.
For example.
Somebody, somebody, something, something money,
money market market here,
ear open this, this with,
with notice that though.
And the sounds of English T H don't exist in Jamaican Patois.
While these spellings may look strange to people who know standard English,
they're actually phonetic representations of speech, unlike English spelling,
which was basically frozen in time several hundred years ago.
And sometimes doesn't reflect current pronunciation,
sometimes words that have a final consonant cluster in English lose a continent
in Patois. For example, respect.
Respect. You'll notice that the words are often used differently.
NEF from English enough means many or much no respect.
This means much respect. Shocked is used.
That's the general word for speak or talk mic from English.
Mic is used generally for causative. Meaning like both make and let in.
English. Let me tell you something.
Meaning let me tell you something and notice here there's a different variant of
the word, meaning something.
There are also lots of words that are created by compounding other simple.
Words, nozzle, literally.
Nose hole. This means nostril on the middle, literally hand middle.
This means the Palm of your.
Yeah. I walked off. Literally I water. This means tear already.
I literally read them.
This means envious or covetous.
This is actually a lone translation of a phrase in the ICAN language of West
Africa.
[inaudible] and that brings us to words that come from languages other than
English. For example, the word for eat numb.
This word comes from a West African language, perhaps Wolf the word for ghost.
They'll be, this comes from a con.
The word for spider on Nanci. This also.
Comes from a con the word for clumsy or awkward, but fun.
And there's a sprinkling of words from other languages. For example,
the word meaning child Pitney, which comes from the Portuguese word.
Pecky Nino a diminutive form of the word, pet Kendall,
meaning small variations of this particular word appear in numerous Creole
languages around the world. Grammar.
The basic word order of Patois is similar to that of standard English.
For example, this means I speak Patois.
The word order is subject verb object, as it is in standard English.
He is eating.
The cake again. This is SVO. Let's add a little more information.
And my number [inaudible]. He is eating.
Cake that I baked this relative clause is introduced by a relative pronoun
wa, which is the question where it meaning what in English.
It would be strange to use what in this context, but we might use,
which notice that there's a definite article before the word cake D this is
the equivalent of the in English. There's also an indefinite article, ah,
which is the obvious equivalent of standard English. Ah, this word here, ah,
looks like the indefinite article, but it's not it's.
The equivalent of English is in English is before a present participant
indicates the present progressive that an action is ongoing, ah,
functions the same way in Patois, placing it before a verb makes it progressive.
Instead of, ah, another word day can also be.
Used.
This also means he's eating the cake day,
comes from the egg bowl language from the word deep meaning to be, ah,
and they are both used as the copula as well.
Those slightly differently from each other, ah,
is used for equative sentences in my doctor.
He's the doctor de is used with a locative meaning in other words,
indicating location, as in the sentence
there in Kingston here, the word ah, is not a copywriter,
but rather a preposition meaning in or at with adjectives,
a cappella isn't needed this,
this sentence doesn't have the copula. Ah,
the equivalent of is in the standard English translation.
Also notice the demonstrative pronoun Desia, which comes from this here.
Just, this is also possible. We also see ya after book.
It means here another similar sentence is this audible,
meaning this is an old book in the first sentence.
The adjective is the predicate. So the copula isn't needed.
But if the adjective is part of a noun phrase than a copula is used one,
the number one can also function like an indefinite article. In this case,
it would be strange to have, ah, the copula followed by the indefinite article.
Ah, one seems a better fit here. Pronouns.
You may have already noticed some personal pronouns that kind of resemble
English ones. The main ones are.
You note that IM can be either masculine.
Or feminine.
We all know them. The most interesting pronoun here is.
Because it doesn't come from English. It comes from the egg bowl.
Pronoun [inaudible] note that there is no difference between the subject
pronouns and object pronouns in Patois. So for example,
me is the equivalent of both I and me in English.
There are also no separate forms for possessive adjectives.
My car is you simply place the same personal pronoun before the noun
for possessive pronouns like mine in English, the preposition fee,
which means two or four is used before the pronoun.
Not that you are offering me word for word that their car is to me,
but in natural English, that car is mine.
The preposition fee is also used before verbs like to in English.
He loves.
To boast big up is a phrasal verb.
Meaning to give someone a thumbs up or show respect to someone fee is not always
used before a verb where you would have an infinitive in English.
It seems to depend on the verb that comes before.
And in some cases it seems to be optional.
And since we're on the topic of verbs,
there are basically no verb conjugations in Jamaican Patois with the exception
of some words like Phoebe, meaning to be in English,
which has a different conjugated form, but still it's only one conjugated form.
Ah, so present tense verbs have just one form regardless of the subject.
In the married Emory.
As we saw before the present progressive can be expressed by adding ah,
before the verb or day he's reading a book.
The past tense is sometimes not indicated and needs to be inferred from the
context, but it can be indicated with one of three markers.
When did or Ben.
Invalid readable, readable.
These sentences mean he read a book in the simple past the progressive marker,
ah, can also be used with the past tense to express the past. Progressive.
When I read a book, he was.
Reading a book. Ben is more like a present. Perfect progressive marker.
Ben readable. This means.
He has been reading a book.
The future is normally expressed using the verb goal. As an English Denmark,
I read a book, they are going to read the book.
Our goal is like are going to in English.
And the future is also often expressed using. We like will in English.
Then we read the book. They will read the book and the different sentence.
Since I'm tired of talking about people, reading.
Jonathan asleep on the bed there, John will sleep on that bed.
John would sleep on the bed.
Notice here at the preposition pun,
which means on or upon the word it descended from.
Also notice that day.day, literally that there, which we saw before.
Notice that that day can be split by the gnome with that coming before and day
coming after questions. Yes or no.
Questions are simple in Patois. You simply raise your intonation.
You ain't Rob beach. Did you go to the beach? We're forward. It's.
You past tense. Marker. Go to beach.
Notice that there's no question in version or use of did as there is in English.
It's no different from the sentence. Meaning you went to the beach,
except that it has rising into a nation. And again, here we see the word, ah,
used as a preposition showing movement towards something like two in English
for open questions, many of the interrogative pronouns. In other words,
question words, resemble English ones with some phonological changes.
What do I do? What are you doing? Where you are going? Where are you going?
Who have the book? Who has the.
Book? But there are some differences too, like the way to ask why?
Well I'll make from English. What make making my ball? Why is she crying?
Notice the word ball, which in English means to cry loudly or uncontrollably,
but in Patois it just means to cry.
Now that we've had a look at some of the basic features of Jamaican Patois,
let's look at a couple more sentences and see what we discover because I don't
know where my wife is. I have to go cook dinner for myself.
No, and my wife today may have to go cook dinner for myself.
Word for word it,
because I know no where my wife
is locative.
I have to go cook dinner for myself.
The first word true means because,
and indicates the reason for something me means I,
because it's the subject in the sentence.
No is the basic way of expressing a negative as an English in the simple
present. In other words, for habitual action or States, no is used by itself,
but with other tenses or aspects,
it can combine with the tents or aspect marker.
The present progressive negator is NA a combination of no. And ah,
the progressive aspect, marker.
This is also used to express negation in the future.
And also Neveah liver is used for the past. Like never in English,
in the phrase, me wife, me functions as a possessive adjective.
Like my remember that day is the copula that is used for locative,
meaning indicating location.
Huffy means half to a combination of half and fee.
Meaning to Dina means dinner and feed self means for
myself with feet,
meaning two or four and one final sentence.
So I'm going to like them people then chapter.
This means I don't like those people. They talk too much word for word it's.
I know like those people,
they excessively chatty in the sentence. We can see Dem twice,
but used in different ways. The first Dem is a demonstrative adjective.
Like those in English. In the second instance, it's the subject pronouns.
They them is also used in a different context as a plural marker with
them coming after the now they're post them means the cats
is them means my ears notice that IAS from English ears is
normally singular in Patois to be made plural.
It's followed by Dem after that chatty chatty chop, the Chuck D.
This is a redo application of the word chatty,
which means chatty redo application is common in Jamaican Patois sometimes to
intensify an adjective like in this case, as you can see,
Jamaican Patois is quite similar to English in many ways.
And with that sliding scale between full-on Patois on the one hand and standard
English on the other certain speakers,
Patois is more mixed with English than others that leads some people to believe
that Patois is nothing but English spoken with a Jamaican accent with a little
bit of slang thrown in,
but the full-on Patois basil elect has its own grammatical features its own
vocabulary and its own phonological features that make it quite distinct from
standard English.
The question of the day to anyone from Jamaica or Jamaicans living abroad,
to what extent do you use Patois?
And to what extent do you use standard English?
Does it depend on the situation and to speakers of English,
native speakers or otherwise? What do you think of Jamaican Patois?
How much of it are you able to understand?
I'll add some links in the description of this video.
So you can hear some more real life samples of Patois.
If you enjoyed this video,
check out the different Lang focused social media accounts like Facebook,
YouTube, Twitter, Instagram, et cetera. And as always,
I want to give a very special thanks to my Patrion supporters,
especially my top tier Patrion supporters whose names appear right here on the
screen, many special thanks to them and to everyone.
Thank you for watching and have a nice.
No.